hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my second attempt of
slender claustrophobia where am I
I need to get out of here I knew to do
is feeling that something is following
me he's following me yes something is
you're screwed buddy alright so I'm
gonna be intelligent about this I
discovered that people were telling me
that you don't need to get all of them
you just need to get some of them and
try and also try to stay around
landmarks that are visible they'll go to
the outer edges try to get inside and
start getting keys so I'm gonna play
smart about this
you're gonna beat him I'm gonna win I'm
not gonna win probably not okay so I
mean towards the inside now ah there's
the landmark that everyone was talking
about like the big statue that you can
see from space is the one haha ah so and
the reason why slender becomes so
aggressive Slendy become so aggressive
is because you can win after about five
depending on how lucky you is so this is
my landmark there are many like it I've
done that now I think not
alright so stay around here avoid the
outskirts try to keep it localized and
everything
I got this no need to be afraid little
webcam all your viewers out there you
don't need to be afraid I'm the one here
being afraid for you hmm
Mike oh come on one of the things that I
couldn't find was a map to help me out
but that's okay
because I have the memory of a wombat
and this agility of a of a snake or
something I don't know I'm not good with
analogies just trying to do the best I
can with what I have now right now
that's two keys so that's a start
there's the wall I try to avoid hitting
walls and just keep the insides all
right as soon as I hit five I'm gonna
bolt through the door as soon as I hear
five huh all right that's three I'm
doing okay
Wendy's kind of Wow I'm gonna hit a wall
here I know I said I wasn't gonna but
what else whatevs
all right so I know that there I know I
spent a lot of time last time I played
up in the northern quadrant so I know
that there are many around here I got up
to five before but I wasn't able to make
it back to the door okay let me see here
I don't think there
I don't think there's one over here yep
I didn't think so
oh he's gonna show up at any minute now
he's gonna show up he's gotta be here is
it booty beat it would you beat him
would you meet him okay go back inside
towards the stash here ah
Slendy can you go please I don't want to
play today I just want to get this and
get done no nothing nope nothin okay
cause I'm about hitting the median of
the statue up there that's a dead end
Frigga frak I'm supposed to be trying to
avoid going to the walls but I am NOT
azam an idiot all right nothing yet I'm
actually surprised that Slendy has not
appeared no not yet cuz last time I got
stuck with only finding one and he did
he show DUP like right away now I'm Ken
freaked out cuz I know he's just gonna
pop around a corner I know he is okay
come on in there please yes yes yes yes
yes
no no that's bad oh oh no oh no
Oh No okay have I been here I don't
think so because I'm on the other side
of that statue so if I go down this path
I could find a fifth one and maybe maybe
push for a six months just felt my
chances okay this way it's just going to
loop oh maybe maybe this ah ha ah it's a
guy Wow that's him that's that's my good
buddy I'm gonna go try I'm gonna go try
I got five
I got a 50% shot you know any pity pity
pity come on come on buddy come on buddy
he's not that bad he's not that bad come
on my veggies yeah bye not that bad not
that bad now dead bad can I come on I
think it all is that oh no it's not
it was not okay hurry less a little bit
it's a little bit obey okay
catch your breath you okay catch all
right
I know it's over here please tell me
it's all here this is the right way to
the thingy right you see this is 16
I just want to kind of cover anything
can give me a better chance is Oh a okay
in my book by essence plenty been
showing himself why has he not
why why why is he very why is he being
so wait a minute oh no oh no what have I
done oh where am i where am I Bama Burma
I know oh no where am i did I get turned
around I thought it come again I thought
it was on this side haha oh no oh no
where am i where am I
I know it's gonna be over here buddy not
wait no oh don't let's it put me in all
know this but oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no where am I BAM boom
oh it's probably on that side oh hello
statue I'm good where's e-stop dong and
Dumpty dong in I don't know Tommy
is it on this side because you know I'm
on which side is it on Oh God
wait a minute ah come on that's where
I've been okay I've been here and her
home oh where the heck am i why am I so
flabbergasted what is that
aha six is good it's great I got six
keys and now I don't know where the hell
I am
oh this is wrong again it wrong again
where am I don't know where they are
where's a damn door
that's six please let me at least try
them please let me at least try I want
to try before I die cuz I know I'm not
gonna get it I know that sound I don't
where the heck am I
I don't remember which way in relation
to the statue that beside that the door
is on must be on that side over there I
don't
I don't know I am no no no no I'm so
hacker girl you're gonna try Slendy
gonna try you're gonna let me try you
gotta let me try you gotta let me try
come on let me try oh don't be nervous
tell me nervous guys on right where is
it
why can't I I've gone denied debye going
everywhere except have I gone to every
side except the one that it's on I'm
such an idiot
why did I not know is why do I not know
this
why am i not find this why am I going in
circle why am i not talk good anymore
where am I
no I don't know I want to get on that
side that wall I don't know I could've
sworn I went to this no no don't get
dark
no you douche don't get dark don't he's
not that close he's not that close he's
close he's close he's really close where
is it
where the Frick and frack is it oh I
hate you so much Lenny right now I hate
you so much I hate you I hate you I hate
you I hate you where these is it where
the food is in please oh come on
what now I've got around their daughter
frigging map
what that wasn't them impossible I've
gone everywhere
where's the damn door I've gone to all
of these sides all of the sides every of
the sides I have been oh and now I can't
framework I think I'm five give me a try
let me try let me try let me try let me
try let me try
Dora Maar failed no no no way click it
you ever mother ticket no no no oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh no oh
open up you
oh I'm so sorry guys I couldn't do it
second attempt failure why am i stupid I
don't know I don't know guys okay all
right that's it for now
cuz next slender map is gonna be
released Slenderman shadow map I should
mention if you want to play it yourself
link is in the description below
annotations to other stuff I've done
have been around here sleep my slender
compilation which is right down there so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye